i've got a pop quiz for you what
database system has been around for
almost 50 years
i guess you can guessed it by the topic
of this video it's a relational database
hello my name is jamil spain developer
advocate with the ibm cloud and brand
technical specialists in the u.s
financial services market in today's
talk we're going to dive a little bit
into relational databases i'm going to
get into some of the characteristics of
the database model and also some
benefits that it provides for you when
making your decision that you want to
use this for your next project
to get started let's talk about the
structure of a relational database
system it's going to
pretty much map out your data points
and bring out the relationships in that
and the way that it accomplishes that is
through the first thing is making tables
which represents
particular items or nouns or particular
entities of your particular system that
you want to actually prototype so let's
say i have a bunch of books
now this is going to be a table
it accomplishes the attributes of these
books by having columns
and columns will be things like name
date
okay maybe author
of course gotta have an author for a
book and every
table is gonna have an id field some way
to uniquely identify it each
each row of this
database table represents an actual
record or an item a type of book that's
how it really
fulfills that ability to hold the
database system there
and then as you wait you kind of query
out this particular system is through
what we call a
sql a structured query language
and it's a particular system you can say
select
all the books
and give me all this data out for me to
use
now we have one particular item here
books but where it really comes you
really see the power of a relational
database let's say now i want to
show the authors
and the way that relational databases
can really provide the structure of
relating these two entities together is
by describing them through a particular
entity or relationships you have one
that you hear about where books can have
multiple authors so maybe a one
two
many
you can have a one
two one
there's just a couple of relationships
you can you can kind of mirror within
the database system so one way that i
can have this kind of normalized
structure is to say definitely the
authors is going to have
its own particular id and name and any
any any particular order of attributes
that i want to describe there
but i can also one of these fields can
be an actual
number that actually relates to the id
of this field this is what's known as a
foreign key
and of course that'll be a name there so
when i do my query the next query i do
i can reference both these tables and
say hey give me all the books and give
me more of the author information from
this table using this foreign key to
describe that particular uh structure
there
now you can imagine you'll be running a
lot of these queries a lot and there are
some benefits or some things that are
provided to help with those to speed up
these queries and make them uh operate
as efficiently as possible
you have the database we'll provide ways
that you can kind of set an index let's
say that i'm often querying and always
trying to pull out by name or by date i
can set an index
on this particular column which will
automatically index all the values so
the next time you run this query is
going to pull from what we like to call
this cache of all the values most
importantly every time new rows are
added
records are added to this particular
table the index keeps building this
recent i like to say cache of all these
values so it's always keeping up to date
uh to work there so this is all the
characteristics of what you kind of have
to model out your particular
application that you want to build and
describe how the entities are related to
each other now let's switch over here to
some of the benefits that you're going
to get out of the box with a a
relational database
that you want to use the first we'll
talk about
is
actual the consistency
now this is useful because let's say
there is some point where i want to run
multiple of these transactions let's say
i'm modeling an inventory system for an
e-commerce application and i have the
need to write several
queries in a row that may manage a
couple of different subsystems but if
one of those queries fails i want the
option to be able to
roll back
the whole set of all those queries just
to make sure that my data always
maintains
some consistency there
the second is the option to do stored
procedures
sounds like a very complicated word
there but think of store procedures as
the ability to write multiple blocks or
functions of code um or if there are a
certain amount of queries that i
continue to always run i can kind of
model these so it takes me less code to
write that particular
to access that same functionality with
less sql code and as you start to get
into more sql
writing with relational databases you'll
see queries can get pretty big another
uh way you can do this as well is
another topic called views here
definitely want to introduce some of
these keywords as you do your deeper
dive you're able to see a lot of these
and it'd be familiar
to you and the last one is a mechanism
to handle locking in the database
and concurrency
why is that important
well
at some point multiple users are going
to want to use the database maybe at the
same time maybe two applications are
going to be adding in books
and if the first application is making a
particular insert into this table
you're going to want to make sure that
the database is locked until that write
is done and then the second application
has its ability to go ahead and make its
insert as well so these are all built
into a lot of the relational databases
that you use a lot of these benefits
will be provided for you out of the box
not necessarily something you'll have to
write in code but just know that you'll
have this at top of mind when you are
kind of selecting to use a relational
database for your next project
i hope this is good for you to
understand the foundation of relational
databases
talk to you next time if you have
questions please drop us a line below
and if you want to see more videos like
this in the future please like and
subscribe